maître koubbi bonjour merci d'avoir pris
le temps de répondre à nos questions
alors la représentation française de
l'eau et se dit que les journalistes rt
france continue d'opérer librement en
france on parle de liberté or on sait
que l'accès à l'elysée toujours refusé à
nos journalistes
et bien bonjour et merci pour votre
invitation vous l'avez rappelé je suis
l'un des avocats de votre chaîne arte
france et je suis directement saisi du
traitement de des difficultés objet de
votre reportage l'assertion la
communication qui a été faite par la
france ainsi que vous le rappeler est
parfaitement mensongère c'est à dire que
je puise en témoigner je vous le redis
j'en suis saisi en dépit de demandes
d'accréditation auprès de l'elysée mais
pour ne prendre que cet exemple vos
journalistes sont systématiquement
bloqué refoulés et ne peuvent pas
accéder aux lieux de pouvoir et
d'ailleurs si vous me permettez une 1,6
il ne le pool ils ne le pouvaient déjà
pas je vous prie de m'excuser durant
l'élection présidentielle le syndicat
national des journalistes snj a pris
part après partie justement pour rt
france en condamnant le refus répété
répété de ces accréditations à nos
journalistes
c'est l'instance qui représente la
profession de journaliste elle dénonce
justement ces pratiques comment l'eau et
ce n est pas au courant
bah écoutez votre votre question me fait
sourire parce que vous savez aussi bien
que moi je le pense que l'ol se est tout
à fait au courant
il s'agit là d'une communication qui est
grossièrement mensongère on ne peut pas
dire aux bénéfices de l'eau et ses yeux
qu'elle ne serait pas au courant dans
les faits comme celui ci ça semble tout
à fait manifeste
notre collègue a présenté justement un
petit sujet concernant voilà sept
c'est ces problèmes que l'on a
actuellement enfin les journalistes de
rtl france on parle de la france qui est
aujourd'hui classée 34e classement de
reporters sans frontières
beaucoup de journalistes sont entravés
dans leur mission
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya vraiment une
censure qui est exercée par le pouvoir
en france
nous sommes à une période relativement
charnière et on l'a vu avec la vague de
contestation des gilets jaunes de
nombreuses violences contre un certain
nombre de vos confrères ont été
perpétrés selon que l'on souhaite les
nommer des violences policières ou à
l'occasion des manifestations et à ce
titre le conseil de l'europe dans son
rapport qui a été rendu sur l'offensive
contre la liberté de la presse a classé
la france dans la liste des dix pays à
suivre
c'est entre guillemets un 10 pays à
suivre alors il faut regarder qui est
également dans cette liste des dix pays
il ya par exemple la turquie ce qui
n'est pas un très bon signe donc deux de
violences a censure on se retrouve dans
une configuration où s'agissant berthé
qui est un sujet je vous le redis que je
connais particulièrement bien on est de
manière perpétuelle dans une volonté de
dire des choses sans en apporter à aucun
moment la preuve
donc on parle s'agissant des rdt et de
des faits qu'elle aurait commis des
faits de feuilles qui use des faits qui
auraient été commis mais sans
strictement jamais donné le moindre
exemple et on se place même sous des
démarches qui aurait été initiée par le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel csa
alors que recherche fait il n'y a pas eu
ces démarches qui ont été faites et arte
a reçu en tout et pour tout une mise en
demeure en trois ans ce qui est à
comparer avec les
les tombereaux de mise en demeure reçus
par les autres chaînes donc il n'y a pas
de sanction qui a été prononcé ni même
de procédure de sanction actuellement en
cours contre la cherté du fait de d'un
détournement informationnel à aucun
moment et pour ceux de vos auditeurs qui
auraient envie de creuser le sujet quand
il y en a une le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel a soldé cette procédure
par une absence totale de griefs
nous sommes sur un sujet qui est un
sujet important je crois qu'il faut le
rappeler c'est un sujet la liberté de la
presse la liberté de communication
d'aider des opinions et des pensées
c'est un sujet qui est consacré par la
constitution en ce qu'elle reprend la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen et plus particulièrement en son
article 11
et il est évoqué dans ce texte qui est
un texte français de l'ordre supérieur
il n'y a rien au dessus de notre
constitution
il est évoqué que il s'agit là de l'un
des droits les plus précieux de l'homme
qui est aujourd'hui en train de d'être
foulé aux pieds d'être totalement violée
à une époque où le gouvernement français
semble céder à la tentation de nous dire
à nous citoyens avoue médias qui est un
bon média et qui n'est pas un bon média
ce qui dans une démocratie est plus que
préoccupant merci beaucoup david koubbi
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes l'un des avocats
de notre chaîne arte france
merci m